here are the nominees for achievement in
visual effects I won my Oscar for being
on the visual effects team for Gravity
finding out that you're nominated it's a
reaction that everybody can understand
and it almost sounds trit to say that it
felt unreal but it felt completely
unreal and through the whole process of
it I tried to step back and just pay
attention to everything that was
happening and the Oscar goes too it just
felt like something that I could never
anticipate would ever happen again
gravity Tim Weber Chris Lawrence David
sh and
neilo I don't know if there was any one
moment where it really all sank in this
is the first Oscar for Tim Weber Chris
Lawrence and David sh even just as I
walked to the stage and all of a sudden
I felt myself zooming back to the 500
mile distance and kind of looking at the
thing and going wow this really happened
and at the same time I was incredibly
humbled because I realized that just a
couple of us were representing the
efforts of so many people while we were
working on the movie I don't think it
ever crossed cross my mind once that we
would be recognized with awards for it I
I don't think I ever really considered
it or thought about it I think it's
reflective of the people that I've
worked with in the industry I'm
surrounded by people that are pouring
the same amount of effort into
everything they do producing work that
is every bit is excellent I was just
incredibly fortunate to have managed to
contribute to a project that broke
through and and stood out in some
way